Okay, so here is our program design. I'm going
to start by opening a browser and playing a
song. So previously, I Googled to find out how
one would open a web browser in python. And I
discovered that there is this function called webbrowser.open. This
function takes in the link I want to open.
I just placed a Youtube address in there. In
fact, this could have been any link you want. Alright.
Let's save the program and run it. I'm going
to call it Breaktime dot Py. Py stands for
Python. To run it, I will click on run,
and then click on run module. Now my hypothesis is
that when we run this program it will open
the Youtube link. Let's see. Oh. It seems like
we have an error. Okay, it says there's an
error in your program, EOL, whatever that means, while scanning
the string literal. Okay? Oh, look Python is
pointing out the error. It seems like I missed
the closing quote, so I'm going to add that.
Let me save the program one more time and
run it. Now I believe it will work.
Hm, another error. You know, when I first learned
how to program, I felt so intimidated by these
errors. Look at them. They are red and in
your face, but to make the program work, we have
to somehow get past them. So, would you mind reading
the error and telling us what you think is the
problem with this code? Enter your responses in this box.